[تصفيق]
في هذه المعركة البطولية 16 مقاتلاً في شقة
تم الكشف عن واحدة في بيت حانون هنا للمرة الأولى
وبطريقة قصيدية أكثر من 50 دقيقة من اللقطات
وتسجيلات من مصادر مختلفة أنا على وشك الموت
أخي هو من هذا القبيل
للوقوف في مواجهة القدم اليمنى من هناك أرى أنه قد فعل ذلك
حدوث نزيف في اليدين والرجلين
لا أعرف ماذا أضع عليه
أول جروح بالكاميرا في أنف دفير المصاب
أصعب شيء هو أنك لا تتوقف عن التسجيل للحظة
ليس لدي غطاء
ليس لدي يد
ياد، أنا أفهم أنك في المنطقة الخطرة
البحر أنت تصرخ اليد اليد التي تنظر إلى اليسار أنا
في تلك اللحظة يدرك أنه لن يكون هناك أحد للمساعدة
لقد اختطفنا صاروخًا، وأرى دفير في عيني
أنا أفهم أن وضعه صعب ولم أعتقد أنه كذلك
سوف يبقى الشعور
سؤال: سأموت لأننا سنموت جميعًا هناك يا عزيزي
اذهب إلى قدميك، اذهب إلى قدميك، كاميرتان
المزيد من الشركة في الطوابق السفلية الذين يقومون بالتسجيل
إجلاء الجرحى الـ13 والقتال
لم يعد الإرهابيون الموجودون في الشركة القريبة مصابين
كاميرا أخرى من فوق طائرة بدون طيار وكاميرا أخرى
من الخمسة الذين قاسوا من جانبهم
القتال لو أتيتكم وأهلكتكم
الوقت وبقولك الكل طلع بخير حتى واحد
لم يمت ماذا تقول لي أنه لا يوجد طريق؟
حالة الحياة في هذا الوقت أسمع الكثير الكثير
صرخات من غرفة المعيشة
ساعدوني، اليد والرجل، أسمع صرخات عالية جدًا
الهستيريا ت
تحت
[تصفيق]
في هذه المرحلة، نقوم بالفعل بجولة في كل شيء
الكلمة في البداية استطلاع من الإرهابيين ثم نحن
البحث في الأرض، نرى حقيبة هناك
حدث لي أحد الخزانات الموجودة داخل طابق القيادة
في الواقع ل